GREG IS NEXT.
[♪]
GREG: YOU HEARD?
WE ARE OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE STATE
GUIDELINES TO START EASING
RESTRICTIONS.
IT’S A THREE-PHASE PROCESS ONCE
A STATE SEES A DOWNWARD TREND IN
COVID CASES.
RESTAURANTS, GYMS AND PLACES OF
WORSHIP CAN OPEN WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES.
AND YOU CAN FINALLY HAVE THAT
ELECTIVE SURGERY.
BUTT IMPLANTS HERE I COME.
AND THOSE AT RISK NEED TO STAY
HOME.
AVOID GROUPS OF 50 OR MORE.
SCHOOLS AND BARS ACROSS REOPEN
WITH MAX HER OCCUPANCY.
FOR STATES WITH NO SIGNS OF A
CORONAVIRUS REBOUND, WORKPLACES
CAN RESUME WITH UNRESTRICTED
STAFFING.
VISITS TO HOSPITALS AND SENIOR
LIVING FACILITIES CAN RESUME.
WHAT DOES NANCY PELOSI CALL THE
GUIDELINES?
VAGUE AND INCONSISTENT.
BUT HOW DIALED IN IS SHE?
LET’S CHECK IN WITH THE BUTT
KISSER TO THE STARS, JAMES
CORDEN.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO SHOW US
FROM YOUR HOME?
>> CHOCOLATE.
CHOCOLATE CANDY, AND THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU CAN GET THROUGH
THE MAIL.
CAN I SHOW YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS THE EPISODE OF CRIPS I
NEVER KNEW I NEED.
>> OTHER PEOPLE IN OUR FAMILY
LOOK FOR OTHER FLAVORS.
BUFF CHOCOLATE.
THEN WE HAVE SOME OTHER
CHOCOLATE HERE.
GREG: HE OFFERED NO PROGRESS CAL
ADVICE.
NOW YOU ARE SHOWING OPEN YOUR
DOUBLEWIDE FREEZER SHOCKED WITH
ENOUGH ICE CREAM TO FEED GUAM.
SIT THIS ONE OUT, NANCY AND KEEP
STUFFING YOUR FROZEN FACE WITH
FROZEN YOGURT.
JOE BIDEN SAID THIS.
>> I WOULDN’T CALL IT A PLAN.
I THINK WHAT HE HAS DONE IS
PUNTED.
HE DECIDED HE DOESN’T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MAKE THE CALL FOR THE
COUNTRY AND HE TALKED ABOUT
PHASES IN THE GENERIC SENSE SEEM
TO ME FROM ALL I LEARNED AND ALL
I LISTENED IN MY MORNING BRIEFS
FROM THE DOCS I TALK TO US
IRRATIONAL AND DOESN’T GIVE YOU
ANY HARD GUIDELINES.
GREG: WHAT THE HELL IS HE
TALKING ABOUT?
IF TRUMP TRIED TO CALL THE SHOTS
JOE WOULD HAVE CALLED HIM A
DICTATOR OR TIE RANT.
TRUMP OFFERS A FRAMEWORK TO LET
THE GOVERNORS MAKE THE CALL AND
NOW HE’S PUNTING?
I THINK JOE IS PROBABLY PLAYING
YADZI.
AS THIS MOMENT IN TIME CONTINUES
SO DO YOU FOR NOW.
THERE ARE STRESSES AND THEY ARE
STARTING TO SHOW.
I AM NOT GOING TO LIE.
IT’S BEEN A STRAIN ON
RELATIONSHIPS.
THIS WAS MY WIFE AND I BEFORE
THE QUARANTINE.
AND THIS IS US NOW.
IT’S GETTING TO EVERYONE AND
CREATING A WORLD OF DISTURBING
MYSTERIES.
WHO IS THE PERSON IN MARYLAND
GETTING HIS MAIL IN HIS
UNDERWEAR.
>> THIS FACEBOOK POST FROM
TOMMYTOWN POLICE.
PLEASE REMEMBER TO PUT PANTS ON
BEFORE LEAVING OUR HOUSE TO
CHECK YOUR MAILBOX.
>> IT’S FUNNY HOW HE GOES OUT IN
HIS UNDERWEAR.
IT’S GOOD ADVICE.
GREG: I HAVE GOT TO WONDER.
I GET IT, NO JOB, NO SCHEDULE,
TV ON ALL DAY.
IT’S LIKE BEING DANA’S DOG.
IN MICHIGAN YOU SAW A MASSIVE
PROTEST AGAINST A GOVERNOR WHO
SAID YOU COULDN’T BUY GARDENING
SEEDS.
IF THAT’S NOT MICROMANAGING,
WHAT IS?
IT SEEMS LIKE AN ESSENTIAL THING
IN A PANDEMIC?
WE’LL TRUST OUR LEADERS UNTIL
THEY PUSH THEIR LUCK, THEN WE
GET PISSED.
NOW WE ARE LOOKING AT A COOL,
CALM COLLECTED AMERICA.
BUT IT COULD BE LIKE THE FAKE
SETS ON THE TV WESTERNS.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT WE ARE ALL
TELEPATHIC THAT YOU AND I BOTH
KNOW WHAT BOTH OF US ARE
THINKING BECAUSE WE ARE THINKING
THE SAME THING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
LET’S SAY YOU AND I ARE IN A BAR
AND SOME DUDE SHOWS UP IN A
SNAKE AND A TUTU.
WE KNOW WITHOUT MAKING EYE
CONTACT THAT THIS PLACE IS
GREAT.
THIS ALSO HAPPENS ON OSCAR
NIGHT.
THIS IS THE THIRD HOUR OF THE
OOZING WOUND OF ENTERTAINMENT.
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY KNOWS IT’S
TIME TO TURN IT OFF AND WE DO.
WE ARE LIKE A BOY BAND.
WE ARE A CONNECTED BRAIN.
OUR HUMANITY UNITES US AND TELLS
US WHEN WE ARE READY.
NOW IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE READY
TO GO BACK TO WORK IN PHASES.
I THINK IT’S WEEK FIVE.
WE ARE PATIENT, WE ARE
PATRIOTIC.
WE ARE ADULTS.
WE DID THE HEROIC THING.
NOW WE HAVE TO DO THE REALISTIC
THING WHICH IS WEIGHING THE RISK
OF BEHAVIOR.
WE SACRIFICED A LOT TO PROTECT
THE VULNERABLE AND WE’LL STILL
DO THAT.
BUT AS THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
INCHES CLOSER TO HORRIFYING.
WE HAVE GOT TO ASK.
WHAT IS ADAM SCHIFF DOING?
HE SAYS HIS HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE IS CONDUCTING
REAL-TIME OVERSIGHT OF TRUMP’S
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE.
BUT FROM HOME.
SO THE GUY WHO CAPTURED ALL THE
ATTENTION, CAUSING THE MEDIA TO
MISS THIS OUTBREAK IS TRYING TO
DO IT AGAIN?
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT HE’S REALLY
DOING AT HOME.
>> AND NOW ADAM SCHIFF
QUARANTINE VIDEO DIARY.
>> REMEMBER, CLEAN HANDS.
ALWAYS REMEMBER, WEAR YOUR MASK.
I MYSELF LIKE TO GO WITH THE
TRIPLE PROTECTION.
COME AND GET ME CORONA.
I THINK IT’S TIME TO FLATTEN
SOME CURVES OF MY OWN.
MAKE IT BURN.
REMEMBER YOUR SOCIAL DISTANCING.
KEEP SIX FEET AWAY AT ALL TIMES.
DID YOU HEAR THAT WILSON?
GET AWAY.
WILSON!
GREG: OH, I MISS HIM.
TRUMP ANNOUNCED WE ARE PULLING
FUNDING FROM THE ABYSMAL WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
>> THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT BY THE
PRESIDENT TO STEER YOU AWAY FROM
HIS OWN ACTIONS.
>> IF YOU GO THROUGH THE SCAPE
GOATS HE BLAMES FOR THIS
PANDEMIC --
>> WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS A
PRESIDENT WHO DEFLECTS DEMEANS
AND DENOUNCES OTHERS AS OPPOSED
TO TAKING RESPONSIBILITY.
GREG: IT’S AMAZING HOW EVERY DAY
FOR THE MEDIA IS STILL THE FIRST
DAY OF TRUMP’S PRESIDENCY.
HE’S FORCE AN ENTITY TO DO A
BETTER JOB OR ELSE.
SHOW THE GUY A TIRE AND HE WILL
KICK IT.
LIKE THE MEDIA HE
UNDERSTANDS:PERSUASION.
THE MEDIA LIKE CHILDREN SEE
TOUGH DECISIONS LIKE SCARY AND
MEAN.
THE ECONOMY WILL RETURN AND YOU
WILL EXIT THIS REAL MOMENT IN
TIME SMARTER, WISER, STRONGER.
WE DID THE RIGHT THING.
WE SACRIFICED A LOT.
MAYBE IT’S TIME FOR SOME OF US
TO GET BACK TO WORK.
IF WE DON’T, WE ARE ALL SCREWED.
BUT YOU DON’T HAVE TO LISTEN TO
ME.
IT’S OKAY.
BECAUSE I’M LISTENING TO YOU AND